I like to Surf Zillow at night who
doesn't I did have a date the other
night where I served Zillow with the
date that was like whoa
I mean wait like so were there deal
breakers was he like I love Berber
carpet and you were like
by the way you're right a barber is very
divisive
carpet he loved it in a way that I was
like help me understand your love of
carpet and he was like growing up you
like if you had carpet you were rich and
I was like Wow same and then we thought
we both loved carpet and then we
discovered like the mold issues and all
of that and so yeah but in his closet
it's the only bit of carpet in our house
and sometimes you know after a cocktail
or six we go in there and we lie down on
the Berber carpet
um would you call that a shag on a shag
I'd call that a shag on a shack yeah ah